[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bienvenue dans ces idées qui gouvernent
le monde France où va ta diplomatie on a
souvent fait reproche à la France
d'avoir une diplomatie en surplomb
sous-entendu arrogante de chercher à
parler à tout le monde dans les conflits
qui parsème la planète d'être toujours à
la recherche d'une influence stratégique
si non politique au sein de la reine
internationale avec de grands succès
historiques talleyrans et le Congrès
deviennent de Gaulle et la France parmi
les grands sortir de la deuxième guerre
mondiale plus proche de nous en 2015 la
conférence sur le climat mais aussi des
échecs sinon des faux pas en Afrique au
Proche-Orient la Libye notamment au
Maghreb vis-à-vis de Trump Erdogan
Poutine qui ne se sont pas prêtés aux
sollicitations françaises certes cela
n'incompagne exclusivement et
exhaustivement à la diplomatie mais au
sein du concert des nations
diplomatie et sécurité sont souvent
liées il en est de même avec le
renseignement et la militarisation de la
politique étrangère des États-nations
notamment lors des crises et de cette
guerre en Ukraine à cela il faut ajouter
que la scène diplomatique nationale
comme internationale doit compter avec
les ONG parfois très activistes des
intérêts financiers bien souvent
corrupteurs les empiètements de
l'espionnage informatique et des
lanceurs d'alerte pour en venir à la
France nous évoquerons également les
contraintes imposées au corps
diplomatique et à cette espèce de
dichotomie stratégie qu'entre puissance
moyenne auquel on nous classe et les
hyperpuissances qui dominent l'économie
mondiale étire les ficelles de la
mondialisation pour en parler je vous
présente mes invités Jérôme bonafon que
nous avons en visioconférence depuis
Genève qui est ambassadeur auprès des
Nations Unies à Genève et des
organisations internationales en Suisse
Yves saint jour vous êtes ancien
ambassadeur au Brésil et en Espagne et
vous êtes président du conseil
d'administration de l'Institut Pasteur
Alain Rouquier ancien ambassadeur
président de la Maison de l'Amérique
latine Philippe jelly mon confrère qui
est directeur adjoint de la rédaction du
Figaro et je crois spécialiste et en
même temps responsable de la politique
internationale
[Musique]
alors partons de cette pensée du général
de Gaulle il faut prendre les choses
comme elles sont car on ne fait pas de
politique autrement que sur des réalités
que je voudrais vous poser pour
commencer ce débat c'est que peut la
diplomatie française face aux réalités
du monde est-ce qu'elle vous paraît bien
orienté en termes d'adaptation à la
conflictualisation de la planète Jérôme
bonafon voulait
nous donner votre première impression
sur ce sujet
je me demande si la citation est
complète parce que le général de Gaulle
il était animé par un projet par une
ambition par une vision par un idéal et
il pensait que la réalité se transforme
et que le but de la politique c'est
d'agir pour que la réalité soit en
accord avec vos intérêts et vos valeurs
et donc oui bien entendu une diplomatie
doit être fondée sur un principe de
réalité mais une diplomatie est animée
par un gouvernement elle est animée par
un président de la République en ce qui
nous concerne elle est animée par un
certain nombre de visions et vidéos et
notamment la conviction que dans l'état
actuel de la société internationale il
faut avoir pour mantra la recherche de
la paix la recherche de la justice la
recherche d'une cohérence entre nos
actions économiques nos actions
politiques nos actions militaires et ça
dans un cadre non seulement national
mais aussi dans un cadre européen mais
alors je vous poserai la question
autrement les autres nations considèrent
que la France
a une politique de grandeur une
politique
arrogante etc qu'est-ce que vous
répondez à ça
de cette diplomatie quand la présidente
de la République invite à Paris
pour un sommet sur un nouveau pacte
financier mondial
chef d'État
dirigeant d'institutions internationales
publiques et privées ils viennent ils
viennent parce qu'ils savent que la
France
s'est porté un certain nombre
d'idées un certain nombre de
propositions et c'est agir sur un
certain nombre de paramètres qui font
que nous sommes considérés comme étant
capables d'aller vers des solutions plus
inclusives plus intéressantes plus
pragmatique il s'agit pas d'avoir une
diplomatie de la grandeur ça n'a pas
beaucoup de sens il s'agit d'avoir une
diplomatie ambitieuse pour construire
les éléments de la paix de plus de
stabilité dans un monde qui comme vous
le disiez est brutal et conflictuel et
travailler par des tensions extrêmement
fortes Philippe jelly qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez vous en tant que journaliste
et observateurs privilégiés de la
politique internationale pour Le Figaro
il me semble effectivement qu'on peut
pas faire de diplomatie en dehors des
réalités ou alors on
des résultats probablement assez assez
lunaire il y a les réalités pour moi
c'est un mélange de en fait trois
piliers les réalités les principes qui
sont importants et comme l'a dit géant
bon à fond les ambitions les objectifs
qu'on se fixe et
il peut y avoir du jeu
dans la machine entre les ambitions les
moyens qu'on se donne les principes
qu'on respecte ou plus ou moins et c'est
là où évidemment le débat commence sur
la politique étrangère d'un pays en
l'occurrence la nôtre également
pour moi les choses sont assez sont
assez claires d'abord c'est pas parce
que les difficultés ça Moussel qu'il
faut renoncer à essayer de construire
quelque chose et c'est effectivement
souvent dans les difficultés que des
propositions
paraissent ils réalisent difficile à
mettre en oeuvre et à ce moment là on
est taxé de on est taxé de tous ces
adjectifs dans dont il a été question
mais quoi la diplomatie c'est c'est quoi
c'est des intérêts un diplomate va
défendre les intérêts de son pays c'est
des valeurs évidemment et tout ça c'est
des réalités y compris les valeurs c'est
des réalités parce que les autres ont
d'autres valeurs
et et des alliances qu'on a qu'on
construit qu'on fait évoluer et qu'on
met au service de des propositions qu'on
fait par conséquent dans dans ce cadre
moi je considère que
que certes il est tout à fait
absurde de faire des propositions en
l'air sans tenir compte de ces réalités
ou de ses intérêts mais que proposer
proposer encore et avoir l'outil
diplomatique pour pour faire avancer les
choses
arrogance de la diplomatie française je
le récuge totalement d'abord parce que
cette idée que la France est en deuxième
classe et plutôt voyage en première
classe avec un ticket de deuxième classe
que les Américains nous lancent la
figure très souvent ça tient pas la
route c'est parce que c'est pas en
fonction de l'importance économique
d'un pays qu'on peut juger de sa
diplomatie un pays peut avoir une
diplomatie et même un état quand le
Vatican et diplomatie extrêmement active
et mondiale et c'est pas une comparaison
mais enfin il est vrai que ça ne dépend
pas de l'étendue du territoire sinon à
ce moment-là la Russie aurait la
première diplomatie du monde ce qui
n'est pas tout à fait le cas je crois
que la France a une tradition
diplomatique quel que soit le nom qu'on
lui donne qui a un certain nombre de
volets
des responsabilités mondiales parce que
nous avons un passé nous avons un
présent où nous sommes présents dans
l'adopécifique
en Afrique en Amérique latine qu'on
habite trop souvent ou nous avons
beaucoup d'intérêts économiques et une
présence culturelle très forte et la
France ne fait pas mauvaise figure et en
puissance atomique et étant membre du
Conseil de sécurité et des Nations Unies
donc je crois que l'arrogance ne la voit
pas la France a comme présent et avenir
l'Europe et là le devoir de participer à
la résolution des problèmes des conflits
mais aussi des défis mondiaux on va en
parler des problèmes communs
je ne balai pas d'un revers de main
l'accusation d'arrogance d'abord parce
que elle nous est imputée par souvent
nos partenaires y compris en Europe et
pas seulement nos adversaires ce n'est
pas nécessairement une critique qui
n'est pas constructive et ensuite
ça n'est pas l'appareil diplomatique le
petit diplomatique qui est arrogant ce
qui est arrogant parfois c'est la
politique étrangère qui en France est
décidée par un homme et une toute petite
équipe et ensuite mise en musique par
cet appareil cet outil diplomatique qui
est riche qui est puissant mais on fait
quand même souvent une diplomatie de
coût plus que de stratégie ou disons que
les coûts ont tendance à faire de
l'ombre à la stratégie parce que tout ça
est décidé à l'Élysée entre trois
personnes alors j'ai en bon à fond
peut-être que vous voulez répondre à ce
que vient de dire Philippe jelly mais je
voulais avec vous approfondir cette
question avant d'être à Genève vous avez
eu des fonctions auxquelles Orsay quand
on parle d'un projet industriel on parle
de maître d'oeuvre et de mettre
d'ouvrage quand on parle d'une action
militaire on parle de chaîne de
commandement mais pour la diplomatie
française qui sait qui décide et comment
ça se passe entre le domaine réservé
présidentiel dont je rappelle que ça
n'est pas dans la Constitution le Quai
d'Orsay et l'ambassadeur qui lui est
dépositaire de l'autorité de l'État dans
le pays où il est accrédité comment ça
fonctionne
en quelque sorte c'est qui qui initie
c'est qui qui décide et qui comment ça
se passe
il n'en va pas différemment de la
diplomatie des autres chapitres de
l'action publique il y a d'un côté un
gouvernement il y a une légitimité
démocratique dans notre cas il y a la
tête de l'État un chef de l'État qui est
investi de pouvoir que la Constitution
lui confère et que la pratique
institutionnelle lui confère et il y a
un appareil d'État avec des hauts
fonctionnaires des fonctionnaires moyens
des fonctionnaires territoriaux des
fonctionnaires nationaux qui sont
chargés d'abord d'une mission
d'expertise et de conseils ensuite d'une
mission de mise en œuvre une fois la
décision prise et cela dans un dialogue
permanent entre la haute fonction
publique et le gouvernement et je crois
qu'il n'en est pas différemment dans la
diplomatie ce dont le gouvernement a
besoin c'est du diplomate qui lui donne
de façon précise experte rigoureuse
impartiale l'état des lieux de la
situation mondiale géographique monsieur
Rouquier parlait de l'Amérique latine il
faut connaître l'Amérique la platine
dans ses racines les plus profondes pour
pouvoir porter un jugement intelligent
sur ce qui se passe au Venezuela au
Brésil à Cuba ou Honduras où nous avons
des intérêts en Argentine etc ensuite il
faut les sur les problèmes globaux le
changement climatique la santé mondiale
le numérique le terrorisme les questions
nucléaires il faut des gens qui à la
fois connaissent la substance technique
des questions et en même temps
connaissent la façon dont cette
substance se joue à travers les rapports
les rapports de force mondiaux et donc
c'est là que se situe le rôle du
diplomate dans l'expertise ensuite le
Président la ministre le gouvernement
décide entouré de ses avis et une fois
la décision prise la diplomatie exécute
c'est un mécanisme de dialogue permanent
entre les uns et les autres et il ne
faudrait pas vivre dans un état dans
lequel la technocratie l'emporterait sur
le politique pas plus qu'il ne faudrait
vivre dans un méthode dans lequel le
politique méprise la technocratie et la
réalité des choses telles qu'elles vont
YVES SAINT un jour on vient d'entendre
Jérôme bonafon dire que c'est
l'ambassadeur qui envoie quelques notes
si on peut voilà et que c'est sur ces
notes là que qu'une décision se prépare
s'aggments etc mais est-ce qu'on est sûr
que
tant au Quai d'Orsay canalisés
ça fonctionne et que les notes sont
prises en considération il a dit un peu
plus que ça et il a dit qu'il y avait
une chaîne qui
redéploie au sein du ministère des
Affaires étrangères il y a évidemment
les les directions de l'administration
centrale et aussi
la capacité de collecter d'autres
informations en interministériel ou
directement et évidemment il y a aussi
on évoquait l'Amérique latine le plus
proche du terrain la compréhension de ce
que sont chacun des
de ce que chacun des pays de chacun des
pays ces positions ces valeurs ces
principes c'est ses actions alors moi je
considère que c'est parfaitement exact
et je considère même peut-être de la
même de ce qu'a dit de ce qu'a dit
Jérôme bonafond que le Quai d'Orsay
c'est comme un dans le dans
nos institutions de la Cinquième
République est contenue du rôle
spécifique du président de la République
du domaine réservé c'est presque un
grand cabinet du Président de la
République qui est
véritablement dédié par à la fois ces
initiatives propres dans les ambassades
ou à l'intérieur du ministère ou par les
demandes qui lui sont faites à cette
expertise ces conseils c'est ces
conseils de mise en œuvre c'est ces
projets et évidemment des discussions
aussi là où chacun est avec les autres
donc oui je considère véritablement que
au-delà même de des autres départements
ministériels on est dans on est tout à
fait dans on est tout à fait dans cette
ligne et au service d'une politique
étrangère que les diplomates ne
définissent pas directement qu'ils
mettent en œuvre qu'ils mettent en
musique alors maintenant à la question
précise c'est est-ce que toutes les
notes est-ce que tout ça est pris en
considération
précisément la question c'est définition
d'une politique étrangère à Port des
serviteurs de cette politique étrangère
que sont les diplomates
certainement que la réponse est non
parfois parce que une ligne politique se
dégage pour qui ne va pas dans le sens
de ce que va conseiller l'ambassadeur
une politique plus générale
se fait et c'est vrai que de temps en
temps on peut être éventuellement déçu
par la décision qui est prise ou pas
prise d'ailleurs
pour aller plus loin là-dessus je
voudrais je vais vous laisser répondre
mais je voudrais préciser cette chose un
de vos collègues pour ne pas le citer
Gérard arrot
déclaré au cours d'une fois d'une
réunion que pour la politique étrangère
selon le degré de proximité entre le
ministre des Affaires étrangères et
l'Élysée ça fonctionnait plus ou moins
bien c'est vrai ça je suis pas là pour
interpréter la pensée
de ça mais je pense que nous avons
beaucoup de chance par rapport à
d'autres pays par exemple aucun
président de la République n'accepter de
créer un Conseil national de sécurité
quand aux États-Unis et qui aurait
marginalisé le Quai d'Orsay et je me
souviens quand j'étais directeur des
Amériques que c'était le conseiller
diplomatique qui me téléphonait en
disant le président d'une autre à telle
heure sur tel sujet tu me l'envoies donc
la chaîne de communication
fonctionne parfaitement et comme le
disait Yves tout à l'heure le Quai
d'Orsay est au service de ceux qui
prennent des décisions c'est à dire de
l'aiguiser et ça ça me semble ça me
semble très bien pas qui est de la perte
en ligne évidemment quand on est en
poste on fait l'information on fait la
synthèse des informations on fait
l'interprétation des informations et on
fait des propositions si on est d'un
vrai ambassadeur qui est conscient de ce
qu'il doit faire dans le pays où il se
trouve et c'est propositions ne sont pas
toujours acceptées parce que ça
correspond pas à la politique du moment
à d'autres intérêts qui veulent des
intérêts intérieurs ou extérieurs
européens ou mondiaux et bon on est là
on est là pour ça mais on est là pour
faire des propositions passablement pour
envoyer de l'information brute et ça je
crois que ça marche assez bien il y a le
filtre des cabinets qui est honnête
problème avec la multiplication des
cabinets qui n'existent pas dans
d'autres pays mais avec des directions
que soit géographiques ou thématiques ça
fonctionne ça fonctionne bien et je
crois que ça va dans le dans le bon sens
à condition d'avoir d'avoir des
diplomates qui soient des experts formés
on va parler justement de la formation
de faire bien leur métier Philippe j'ai
dit là-dessus je crois que je vais être
vous et à décrire le vida le verre à
moitié vide dans cette mais il me semble
que ce que des cris monsieur
la perte en ligne c'est dans le cas
idéal c'est c'est quand tout va bien
c'est le minimum syndical mais on sait
bien qu'il y a un certain nombre
d'administrations un certain nombre de
présidents de gouvernement pas
d'administration ça c'est pour les
Américains qui ont montré une défiance
assez nette pour les ambassadeurs en
général ou pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux sur des sujets de
particulièrement aigus
Nicolas Sarkozy avait voulu créer un
Conseil de sécurité
ça n'a pas marché parce qu'il y avait
des complications constitutionnelles si
je me souviens bien mais il avait quand
même cette intentions et c'est vrai que
souvent nos présidents
qui sont les maîtres quand même de la
politique étrangère peuvent reprocher au
diplomates d'être un peu trop près de
leur sujet d'être du côté du manche
d'être un peu le nez sur le guidon ne
pas avoir assez de recul donc ça se
passe pas toujours de manière aussi
idéale que vous le décrivez
président ou
diplomates leur expertise d'en savoir
trop de te dire compte
plusieurs volets de la même situation si
vous faites ça ça va déclencher ça
j'ai un exemple c'était la déclaration
franco-mexicaine sur le Salvador des 182
quand c'est arrivé de l'Élysée c'était
la déclaration la reconnaissance de
belleligérance du caractère de
belligérant des guerriers héros ouh là
là
on aura dit non mais c'est pas possible
parce que sinon avec les États-Unis et
finalement c'est devenu la
reconnaissance du caractère
représentatif des deux camps voilà ça
sert à ça
parce que je dis que c'est ce qui ce que
nous affirmons n'est pas contenu n'est
pas contradictoire avec ce que ce que je
viens ce qui vient d'être dit il y a des
hommes et des femmes derrière tout ça il
y a des situations derrière tout ça et
de fait il y a il arrive que les choses
se passent comme comme j'ai dit c'est à
dire que défiance confiance sur tel
sujet
tentative mais ça c'est une histoire qui
est une histoire de toujours et ceux qui
ont écrit des livres le savent de
diplomatie parallèles parce que
effectivement on considère que les
ambassadeurs vivent le syndrome de
Stockholm mais sont au service de pays
où ils sont accrédités tout ça existe
tout ça existe ce que mais ce qu'il faut
dire c'est que le dispositif tel qui est
tel qu'il existe et ce sur quoi
j'assistais lui c'est un dispositif
vertueux c'est à dire qu'il est une
administration avec une séparation une
division du travail qui est me
semble-t-il bien faite avec des
équilibres qui sont pas toujours les
mêmes parce que le ministre est plus ou
moins proche du président il est plus ou
moins fort sur un certain nombre de
sujets etc dans l'histoire de en tout
cas dans l'histoire récente de la
Cinquième République voilà non de fait
non ça marche pas toujours
formidablement Jérôme bonafon je
voudrais vous interroger sur sujet un
peu polémique si on peut dire le corps
diplomatique français a compté des
figures illustres parmi ces membres de
positionnement politique
diversifiée à certains qui sont
qualifiés de d'Atlantis d'autres de
tiers mondise bon il proviennent de
formation distinctes la mixité homme
femme finalement tardive mais est en
train de se faire mais à votre avis
est-ce que tout cela est mis en péril en
difficulté
la pérennité diplomatique est en cause
avec cette réforme de la haute fonction
publique et la disparition du corps
diplomatique en tant que corps
spécifique
et il en reste un certain nombre
ce qui a disparu ce qui est en voie
d'extinction plus exactement c'est le
corps des conseillers des ministres et
l'hypotentiels qui fusionnent avec un
grand corps des administrateurs de
l'État et les diplomates n'ont pas aimé
cette réforme parce que elle leur
paraissait ni la spécificité du métier
diplomatique c'est-à-dire cette
expertise à la fois géographique de
civilisation et thématique qui fait leur
caractéristiques et ce mode de vie
il y a eu les états généraux de la
diplomatie à la demande de la ministre
et du président de la République et ce
qu'a dit le président à la fin de ces
états généraux c'est je maintiens le
métier je vais lui donner plus de moyens
mais j'en modifie les conditions
d'exécution en fonction de l'analyse que
je fais de ce que doit être un État
moderne alors à partir de là moi ce qui
me paraît important en tant que
diplomate professionnel c'est que nous
ayons les moyens de faire ce métier un
en recevant la formation qui est
nécessaire pour le faire
deux en étant toujours animés par cette
espèce d'attente cyosité du monde qui
est la marque de fabrique du diplomate 3
en étant inséré dans l'état tel que
l'État est aujourd'hui et 4 en évoluant
dans notre carrière de façon à suivre le
mouvement du monde que ce soit dans ces
technologies dans ces rapports de force
dans l'émergence ou la disparition
depuis 100 etc et de ce point de vue ce
qui est en train d'être accompli comme
réforme sous l'impulsion de Madame
Colonna me semble aller dans la
direction d'une diplomatie qui sera
mieux installée dans l'état et qui
disposera des moyens de compétences
nécessaires pour continuer cette mission
là après il y aura toujours des gens qui
seront nostalgique du système antérieur
il faudra toujours veiller à garder le
professionnalisme et la vocation qui
fait la caractéristique de ce métier
mais je pense moi je suis optimiste sur
l'avenir de des métiers diplomatiques
français en somme c'est comme si vous
étiez des journalistes
sans carte de presse c'est-à-dire vous
perdez cette spécificité mais ça vous
considérez que c'est pas gênant pour
l'innovation diplomatique et
quand quand le général de Gaulle est
ceux qui l'ont servi ont créé les Nara
ils ont créé un corps des
administrateurs civils qui avait
vocation à rassembler l'ensemble de la
fonction publique interministérielle
c'est un petit peu la même chose qui est
en train de se passer comment va-t-on
garder la spécificité du métier de
diplomate tel qu'elle a besoin d'être
dans un état ouvert sur le monde et sur
l'Europe et comment va-t-on en même
temps faire vivre cette ouverture à
l'interministérielle qui est plus
nécessaire que jamais compte tenu des
thématiques que la diplomatie brasse
maintenant moi je pense que c'est un
métier de vocation et je pense que ceux
qui dans la durée voudront l'accomplir
sont des gens qui sont animés par cela
et que ceux qui ont une vague curiosité
de diplomates pendant un certain temps
oui
occuperont des fonctions de diplomate de
temps en temps souvent avec talent mais
que ce ne sera pas leur vie et que ce
sera un passage dans une existence
est-ce que vous en pensez vous Philippe
Gelly en tant conservateur il me semble
que on est quand même encore dans un
système de de diplomate profite
professionnelle en France heureusement
d'ailleurs et que en dépit de cette
réforme qui effectivement passe mal et
dont on ne saisit pas très bien la
valeur ajoutée pour être franc
de mettre dans un pot commun
des fonctionnaires d'un certain grade
bon ça va permettre certainement comme
le dit Jérôme bonafon a des hauts
fonctionnaires qui viennent d'autres
corps ou d'autres administrations
d'avoir comme ça de faire une incursion
dans la diplomatie on en est quand même
pas au point où en sont les États-Unis
où chaque président nomme dans les
meilleurs postes ou les postes les plus
prestigieux des ambassadeurs qui sont en
fait des contributeurs à ces campagnes
qui sont qui portent effectivement la
diplomatie de leur pays c'est
généralement des donateurs et voilà oui
certes mais lui une fois qu'ils sont
dans leur poste ils ont quand même
toutes les tâches de l'ambassadeur à
accomplir et parfois il y avait plus ou
moins de bonheur donc on est nous je
pense toujours en France dans un schéma
de de diplomate professionnel en dépit
de ces petits coups de canif au corps
diplomatique au pluriel
après il faut voir comment sera mise en
œuvre la réforme quelle en pleurs
prendra le la part du non du non
diplomate de vocation dans l'exercice de
la diplomatie et ça je pense que c'est
un peu tôt
[Musique]
vous venez de voir cette citation délit
à Lévis sous la menace de la force armée
sans la menace pardonnez-moi de la force
armée la diplomatie n'est que j'apprends
de roquet
ça vous fait réagir ça
Yves saint jour
c'est à dire que ne pas considérer que
dans une dans une un conflit ou dans une
négociation difficile
dans pour une pour un moment où on est
dans une politique de puissance quand
c'est la guerre ou la paix que le
recours à la force et
un moyen ça n'est pas raisonnable il
faut penser au recours à la force bien
sûr quand on est dans cette politique ne
pas le faire
ça n'est pas possible et effectivement
il faut de ce point de vue là être être
réaliste alors beaucoup d'autres
personnes l'ont dit d'une autre façon
c'est c'est sûr que il faut il faut y
penser alors nous nous sommes
heureusement il y a mille aspects de la
diplomatie qui ne sont pas à cela et qui
ne
prépare pas la guerre mais de fait
aujourd'hui plus que jamais ou plutôt
après 75 ans en Europe de comment dire
notre tranquillité
dans ce genre de question ce genre de
citation revient nécessairement à
l'ordre du jour alors The Rock je
voudrais avoir votre avis là-dessus si
vous prenons les grands événements du
21e siècle le 11 septembre 2001 avec les
attentats aux États-Unis
la crise des subprimes en 2008 les
printemps arabes en 2011 et plus près de
nous la guerre en Ukraine qui a commencé
en février 2022 pour s'en tenir quelques
événements comme ça finalement rien n'a
été prévu
vous voyez ça comme un échec de la
diplomatie en tant que vigie en quelque
sorte pour anticiper les crises parce
que tout ça est arrivé par hasard on n'a
rien vu je voudrais dire plutôt le
contraire
d'empêcher des attentions
logiciel comme un tonnerre pour aller
sur le sujet que vous abordiez
auparavant à quoi cela sert-il d'être le
pays le plus
militairement le plus fort du monde pour
ne pas avoir empêché ses attentats pour
avoir l'Irak ce qui n'a jamais rien
sinon à créer
de la diplomatie française je parle de
la diplomatie en général vous parlez
aussi des rapports entre
la puissance militaire
la puissance militaire n'assure pas
n'assure pas une bonne diplomatie dit
une bonne de réalisation des voisins de
l'Irak par exemple il est évident que la
crise de l'Irak la France elle-même s'y
est opposée avec de bonnes raisons mais
ça a été une catastrophe oui mais ça
c'est venu après les événements du 11
septembre mais tous ces grands
événements sont arrivés là comme le 11
septembre on pensait que il y avait des
capacités de renseignements aux
États-Unis qui étaient particulièrement
pertinentes et particulièrement
développée on a bien vu que c'était pas
le cas donc rien rien n'empêche ce genre
d'événements et quand on diplomates à
eux on leur a reproché de pas avoir
prévu les printemps arabes de pas avoir
prévu ceci cela et c'est vrai ils sont
pas là pour prévoir ils sont là pour eux
pour ce qui est du printemps arabe
tunisien
les diplomates avaient ressenti et le
gouvernement avait dit mais non on
appuie notre ami Mélanie et on a
continué d'appuyer bon il faut bien voir
que les diplomates parfois aux raisons
parfois ils ont tort mais souvent ils
ont le temps d'avoir raison et les
gouvernements parce qu'ils ont d'autres
intérêts ils ont d'autres engagements
ils ont d'autres visions du monde disent
bah non ce que vous dites là on peut pas
l'accepter parce que bon ça va exploser
mais non vous en faites pas
on a vu ça à cette époque là pour la
Tunisie du moins c'est pas votre
sentiment Philippe jelly que ça ça
explose et finalement c'est après les
journalistes peuvent être solidaires des
diplomates je pense on n'est pas on
n'est pas tellement meilleur pour
prédire les catastrophes je pense que
avant le 11 septembre
un certain nombre de gens savaient que
Ben Laden existait que c'était quelqu'un
à surveiller de là à dire que que les
événements allaient se produire comme
ils se sont produits même le FBI aux
États-Unis il y a un rapport de de 1500
pages du Congrès américain oui il y a eu
des erreurs humaines il y a eu des gens
qui n'ont pas connecté les les dots
comme on dit
franchement on peut pas c'est un peu
commode de mettre ça sur le dos des
diplomates à mon sens et vous Jérôme
bonapon qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ce
côté non anticipateur je me souviens
pour parler de notre pays la guerre en
Ukraine deux semaines avant les
déclarations forts nombreuses de
certaines personnalités politiques
militaires journalistes étaient qui
auraient pas de d'invasion de l'Ukraine
comment se fait-il qu'on n'arrive pas
non pas prévenir mais au moins
anticiper ces choses-là
je pense qu'il faut l'étendre à autre
chose qui sont les rapports de
ressources en général la diplomatie
c'est en quelque sorte la civilisation
des rapports de force ces d'essayer de
régler par la négociation des choses que
les rapports de force économique
culturelles sociaux militaires réglerait
autrement par des moyens qui seraient
brutaux et qui serait l'application plus
récente de la loi de la jungle donc je
crois que c'est à ça que ça sert la
diplomatie deuxièmement je voudrais
faire observer qu'il y a eu des
élections
en Grèce et des élections en Turquie et
que aucun des bons observateurs les plus
experts non vu à quel point les
victoires seraient nettes dans un cas
pour l'Inde dans notre cas pour l'autre
et ça ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire que
en réalité il y a un brouillard sur le
présent et sur ce qui est en train de se
préparer et il y a des circonstances
exceptionnelles dans lesquelles par le
hasard d'une clairvoyance le hasard
d'une information qui arrive vous savez
précisément avant les autres ce qui va
se s'est passé mais dans la plupart des
cas vous êtes surpris par l'accident
vous êtes surpris par ce qui arrive et
votre mission à ce moment-là c'est la
capacité d'adaptation à ce qui vient de
se passer et je crois qu'il ne faut pas
demander au système des choses qu'il ne
peut pas donner un diplomate pas plus
qu'un journaliste comme le disait
monsieur gélier n'est pas un prophète un
diplomate c'est un analyse quelqu'un qui
par ses contacts par sa connaissance du
terrain par SA Expertise arrive à
essayer de décrypter un certain nombre
de choses mais il ne peut pas savoir
lui-même ce que les gens du pays dans
lequel il habite ne savent pas eux-mêmes
je crois que très peu de gens au monde
savaient avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine
que le président Poutine avait décidé
d'envahir l'Ukraine
je crois que ce nombre se compte de
façon très très très restreinte et que
les rues se mêlent l'ignoraient alors
pourquoi voudriez-vous comment
voudriez-vous plutôt que les diplomates
le sachent
on est là ça arrive et voilà ça tombe en
message c'est pas plus c'est journaliste
que les diplomates les événements nous
tombent du ciel comme ça ça ne se passe
pas tout à fait comme ça quand même
c'est à dire que regardez prenez ce qui
se disait en France par exemple deux
semaines avant l'invasion de l'Ukraine
c'est personne n'y croyait personne
n'est quand même un président qui allait
à Moscou pour essayer de convaincre
l'avenir Poutine de ne pas envahir le
crânements américains qui eux étaient
très circonstances et en réalité dans la
question il y a il y a une autre
question qui est celle de savoir si on
n'essaie pas
on ne dépeignant pas complètement une
réalité qu'on redoute de prévenir cette
réalité alors effectivement le travail
du diplomate c'est aussi d'essayer de
faire des propositions comme on le
disait pour prévenir des situations de
ce point de vue là
si vous voyez le
il y a une situation les Américains
semblent savoir qu'il va qui est que
Monsieur Poutine va envahir l'Ukraine
bon il y a une autre situation le
président de la République il va parler
inlassablement avec Monsieur Poutine
pour prévenir cela c'est donc qu'il
craint quand même que ça se réalise ah
bah oui écoutez sortons de ces prudence
fratant de ces prudences mais je
voudrais vous citer trois cas vous
interviendrez de télescopage entre les
failles diplomatiques et des actions
militaires et avoir votre avis alors
Jérôme bonafon pour la première si nous
prenons l'attitude de Barack Obama les
bras ballants réduit à l'impuissance en
2013 face au gazage des populations en
Syrie et l'annexion qui suit l'année
d'après
par Poutine et la Russie de la Crimée
est-ce que vous pensez qui a cause à
effet il y a un lien entre les deux
d'abord je ne crois pas que Barack Obama
soit resté les bras ballants Barack
Obama a fait un choix politique qu'il a
expliqué d'ailleurs longuement dans
l'Atlantique du journal avec lequel les
Français n'étaient d'ailleurs pas
d'accord qui est le choix de ne pas
intervenir militairement en Syrie ce
n'est pas une passivité c'est une
décision de non-intervention et vous
vous souvenez que la diplomatie
française était enfin le diplomatie
pardon le gouvernement français le
président de la République était
convaincu que après l'usage de d'arbres
chimique par le régime syrien il fallait
cette réaction militaire et les
Américains d'ailleurs les Anglais
d'abord
mais sur le télescopage un an après
l'invasion de
l'invasion de la Crimée par Poutine
est-ce que ça vous paraît
il me paraît difficile de faire du
commentaire dans la dans la position
dans laquelle je suis ce que je voudrais
ce que je voudrais je voudrais
légèrement déporter le débat sur quelque
chose d'autre qui est comment réagit-on
maintenant face à une menace nouvelle
qu'est la cybermenace et quels ensemble
de défis nouveau auquel nous sommes
confrontés d'abord par la manipulation
de la vérité et de l'information que
permet cette nouvelle réalité et ensuite
par la capacité technologique d'entrer
dans des systèmes et de pouvoir les les
attaquer très durement et là-dessus ce
que j'observe c'est que sous l'impulsion
de nos autorités le gouvernement dans
son ensemble et le Quai d'Orsay en
particulier sont en train de construire
de nouvelles de nouveaux instruments qui
vont permettre espérons-nous voulons
nous souhaitons nous
d'intervenir contre la désinformation
d'intervenir contre les cyberattaques de
s'armer face à une menace nouvelle
et je crois que là il y a une une
nécessité d'anticipation d'adaptation et
une modernisation et sur laquelle il me
semble que nous devons faire porter
l'accent et si nous voulons rester
pertinents face aux menaces du monde
contemporain merci Jérôme mais enfin sur
cette télescope Philippe j'ai dit
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur un autre
télescope
l'intervention franco-britannique en
Libye en 2011 qui aboutit à la
disparition de Kadhafi
et ce qui suit dans les années après
c'est à dire la dispersion du djihadisme
en Afrique est-ce que vous y voyez un
télescopage avec
certains ont reproché en quelque sorte
d'avoir laissé la Libye dans un état de
décomposition avancée avec toutes les
armes qui sont allées se distribuer en
Afrique c'est pour montrer un petit peu
si vous voulez cette concordance des
temps oui mais on peut effectivement
considérer que c'est un des facteurs qui
ont peut-être contribué à cette
dispersion du djihadisme mais
l'intervention en Libye n'a pas inventé
les djihadistes
tout à fait mais qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de ce télescopage dans le temps
ce que je viens de dire c'est à dire que
c'est probablement une des causes
certainement pas la seule peut-être même
pas la principale
sur votre télescopage précédent c'est
pareil je pense que certains peuvent
avoir le sentiment qu'il y a un lien
parce que Poutine fait une analyse de la
situation dans laquelle il pense que les
États-Unis pour rien au monde
n'interviendront etc mais si l'on veut
faire la démonstration factuelle que il
y a un lien de cause à effet direct
entre les deux c'est impossible parce
que la vie de la planète c'est c'est
comme la vie tout court c'est il y a
toujours des facteurs extrêmement
multiples et variés en l'occurrence je
ne crois pas de manière je dirais
conceptuelle à des télescopages tels que
vous les décrivez d'un d'une cause sur
un effet
et vous qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
alors je prendrai un autre exemple qui
lui est complètement actuel on a eu les
négociations minska minsk2 le format
Normandie etc tout ça les cspérer une
collaboration entre l'Union Européenne
la Russie même Madame Merkel l'avait
initié même au niveau de l'OTAN etc et
finalement
monsieur Poutine décide une invasion
massive à justifier et meurtrière
[Musique]
comprendre de décisions décideurs
américains il n'y avait pas de raison
que de
penser qu'il fallait retendre les
muscles de cette organisation qui était
quand même
nécessaire face à une violation de la
souveraineté de l'Ukraine
particulièrement caractérisée
je pense que
les questions posées ont très à la
situation de la France en réalité parce
que
elle n'est pas isolée mais justement
l'intention et la prétention
d'influencer la politique mondiale dans
la on ne peut pas justement c'est très
intéressant y compris ces exemples parce
que Dieu sait que
dans l'acide en Europe depuis déjà de
nombreuses années les Français parlent
d'autonomie stratégique de capacité de
l'Union européenne à avoir une une
substance une consistance une robustesse
politique
premièrement c'est pour ça que
à un moment le président de la
République a parlé de
l'OTAN et et de son comment comment il a
dit exactement
cérébrale
ce n'est plus le cas aujourd'hui mais on
peut pas
ce qui était clair pour nous c'était
qu'il y avait évidemment une question à
traiter qui n'avait qui n'avait pas été
véritablement traité de même quand on
quand on parle du premier exemple
de nouveau on est dans une situation de
ce type la France est pas le pays le
plus puissant du monde même si on
revient au début de l'émission C'est pas
le pays le plus puissant du monde même
s'il a des atouts des moyens s'il a son
rôle mondial et s'il est de temps en
temps si elle est de temps en temps
considérée comme arrogant dans la mesure
où elle attire l'attention quand même
sur des sur des éléments très très
importants et donc moi ce que ce que je
pense sincèrement c'est que
effectivement on a on c'est un concours
en quelque sorte de
de volonté un peu européenne il faut
bien le dire de continuer dans cette
espèce de de long chemin de la paix
depuis 75 ans qui a fait que la montée
des périls n'a pas été véritablement
perçue et qu'on a pris des et qu'on a
souvent pris des mesures
timides on va dire les choses comme ça
voilà c'est c'est ça mon avis je danse
et dans cette question il faut penser à
la politique étrangère de la France et
aux diplomate parce que minska minsk2
toutes ces choses là beaucoup de
diplomates français ont fait une
expertise on fait des analyses de ces
situations là et elles étaient pas
forcément optimistes sur l'effectivité
de
de ce qui était en train de se passer je
me souviens très bien de tous les
dispositifs qu'on a mis qu'on a mis en
place
aujourd'hui on considère que Poutine à
berner beaucoup de monde
Jérôme bonafon je vous ai écouté sur la
diplomatie et la cybersécurité est-ce
que vous iriez plus loin en cas de
conflits est-ce qu'on peut avancer vers
une militarisation de la politique
étrangère sans aller à ce qui s'est
passé aux États-Unis on se souvient
qu'en Rick et singer était à la fois un
moment donné secrétaire d'État et
conseillé à la sécurité mais est-ce que
vous pensez que en période de crise il y
a une dimension nouvelle à prendre je me
souviens que il y a quelques années
Laurent Fabius ok d'Orsay avait
considéré que au regard de la
mondialisation arrogante cette fois
justifiée il fallait que le Quai d'Orsay
prenne en considération
les échanges économiques dans le monde
est-ce que vous pensez que là à ce
niveau-là il y a une orientation
nouvelle à trouver
la diplomatie est globale une diplomatie
qui serait
mono directionnel serait la diplomatie
d'un pays qui n'a qu'un seul rôle dans
le monde or la France elle est à la fois
une puissance européenne
elle est un pays francophone elle est un
membre de l'Alliance atlantique elle est
un pays qui a une culture mondiale elle
est un pays qui a des intérêts
économiques dans le monde entier et donc
sa diplomatie par définition doit être
une difficulté aussi qui embrasse
l'ensemble du prisme des relations
internationales premièrement
deuxièmement il est certain que comme le
disait Yves saint jour le président de
la République chef de l'État chef des
armées responsable premier de la paix de
la sécurité nationale doit pouvoir
compter sur un appareil diplomatique qui
est parfaitement affûté face aux menaces
telles qu'elles se présentent à à
laquelle on a besoin d'aide et par
conséquent il est évident que depuis les
attentats en particulier de de que nous
avons connu contre Charlie Hebdo ou
le Bataclan on a eu une diplomatie qui
s'est énormément investi sur toutes les
questions de sécurité anti-terroriste
dans un rôle différent de celui des
armées ou des services de renseignement
mais dans un rôle de d'animation d'une
d'un renforcement de la dimension
prévention protection répression du
terrorisme à l'échelle mondiale
aujourd'hui nous avons affaire à un
certain nombre de dirigeants dans un
certain nombre de pays qui pensent que
le recours à la force devient redevient
une méthode normale banale de règlement
des conflits avec les Européens avec le
temps à nous de démontrer que cette voie
là est une impasse et de ce point de vue
la question de l'Ukraine est une
question absolument capitale parce que
de la réponse qui sera donnée de la fin
de cette guerre va dépendre en grande
partie l'avenir du recours à la force
dans les relations internationales
demain et il est évident que pour un
pays comme la France et un continent
comme l'Europe il serait catastrophique
qu'on banalise le recours à la force et
que tout ce qu'on a fait depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale pour construire
l'Europe pour construire un système de
sécurité collective etc etc nous conduit
à vouloir mettre en place par une
combinaison appropriée de moyens
militaires de moyens de renseignement de
moyens cybers de moyens diplomatiques de
capacités économiques et financières un
système de prévention et de règlement
des conflits alors justement nous allons
conclure là-dessus à savoir
est-ce qu'à votre avis et ce sera un
petit peu la conclusion je vous
laisserai à chacun une minute la guerre
en Ukraine on sait pas quand elle se
terminera comment elle se terminera etc
mais est-ce que votre avis dès à présent
on a elle a changé les rapports de force
on était dans on a connu une guerre
froide est-ce qu'aujourd'hui on va vers
un ordre occidental et en avec des
démocraties libérales et en face des
dictatures ou des en tout cas des
régimes autoritaires expansionnistes
est-ce qu'on est déjà rentré dans cette
nouvelle phase là Philippe gélix
mais est-ce que vous ce changement est
en cours aujourd'hui oui bien sûr je
pense que la garant du crèche en Ukraine
change les fondamentaux de beaucoup de
choses en Europe sur le continent sur
les équilibres planétaires
aussi la posture de la France qui est
compliquée de vouloir mener de cette
être cette puissance d'équilibre entre
les blocs alors que il faut quand même
un certain moment choisir son camp et
même nos alliés nous y poussent donc oui
je pense que la donne est nouvelle
en un mot je dirais pour moi le problème
de la France est pas tellement sa
diplomatie c'est même pas du tout sa
diplomatie c'est beaucoup plus souvent
sa politique étrangère qui a quand même
enchaîné pas mal d'échecs avec Poutine
avec sea Jinping avec train avec même
Biden récemment sur
[Musique]
l'inflation actes etc donc on a quand
même un diplomate en chef qui est très
très ambitieux très actif sur actif mais
qui n'a pas la crédibilité
la plus forte et à cet égard ce que vous
avez évoqué tout à l'heure je m'en tiens
là mais
le déclassement de la France à la fois
économique et militaire il joue dans sa
crédibilité pour moi il n'empêche pas
d'être une puissance active mais il
entame sa crédibilité quand deux mots
vous pouvez dire quelque chose Yves
saint jour
on a très peu de temps
que la guerre en Ukraine est fait
changer les lignes c'est que
des enjeux très très importants soit
derrière cela en termes qu'expliquer
très bien Jérôme bonafon sur la
nécessité de construire un dispositif de
sécurité collective qu'on Europe nous
n'avions pas véritablement construit il
faut pas l'oublier mais on a très peu
de très important dans ce que vous avez
dit est-ce que ça va être ouest game the
reste est-ce que ça va être l'Ouest
contre
Occident contre les autres ouais l'ouest
c'est-à-dire un accident contre tous les
autres est-ce qu'il y a un Sud global et
ben c'est sur ces questions là qu'il
faut qu'on travaille nous et la
politique étrangère française et
notamment la diplomatie évidemment dans
un continent que nous connaissons bien à
la roquet moi la mer éclatine où il y a
des démocraties presque que des
démocraties merci
nous avons changé d'époque c'est évident
c'est pas uniquement les gars Ukraine il
y a eu le covid il y a eu une certaine
mondialisation du au covid d'ailleurs
des fragmentations mondiales des rêves
d'Empire qui nécessitent avec une forte
configuration conflictualité il y a pas
que la Russie et la Chine et la Turquie
il y a l'Iran donc il faut avoir des
capacités de prévention de riposte et il
faut s'appuyer aussi je vais finir comme
mon collègues sur des pays démocratiques
qui partagent nos valeurs et qu'on a
oublié beaucoup trop Jérôme pour
terminer mais vraiment un mot vous
considérez que la France est redevenue
un pays occidental avec la guerre en
Ukraine je crois que la France doit
définir ce qu'elle veut en ayant une
sorte d'ambition pour l'avenir c'est à
dire que il ne faut pas regarder vers le
passé il ne faut pas définir le rôle de
la France par rapport à ce qu'elle a été
il faut définir le rôle de la France par
rapport à sa situation en Europe par
rapport au fait que le monde connaît une
transformation énorme une transformation
technologique
économique démographique de civilisation
en quelque sorte et il faut toujours
vouloir que la France est un message
moderne et optimiste pour l'avenir
apporté et ce message y tient en un mot
ça s'appelle l'humanisme c'est ce qui
fait notre notre creusée de civilisation
et c'est ce qui fait que nous sommes
écoutés sur les 5 continents avec nos
forces et nos faiblesses mais en tout
cas en étant un pays français pleinement
français européen et avec des ambitions
mondiales merci Jérôme bonapon écoutez
il me reste à vous remercier d'avoir
participé à cette émission je voudrais
remercier également l'équipe de LCP mais
avant de nous quitter je voudrais
d'abord citer une bibliographie je
rappelle Jérôme bonafon diplomate
pourquoi faire va vous saurez tout c'est
publié chez Odile Jacob sur le mythe le
métier de diplomate je voudrais rappeler
un ouvrage de Sylvie Berman madame
l'ambassadeur de Pékin à Moscou une le
diplomate Sylvie Berman raconte son
itinéraire de diplomate Alain Rouquier
je rappelle que vous avez écrit un
ouvrage
d'anticipation qu'ils appellent la fin
des diplomates rue de Seine c'est bien
ça et bien ça mais c'est pas une
anticipation de la fin diplomate il faut
le lire pour savoir ce que j'ai voulu
dire voilà bon il faut le lire je
rappelle également de Maurice Weiss et
Yves saint jour diplomatie française un
ouvrage très ambitieux où on a un peu
tous les outils les acteurs depuis
1980 et ça a été publié chez Odile Jacob
vous avez un livre à nouveau
à proposer celui de la correspondance
diplomatique du Figaro Isabelle Lasserre
Poutine Macron Poutine les liaisons
dangereuses voilà bah écoutez il me
reste plus qu'à vous remercier à nouveau
et nous terminerons sur cette citation
je crois à la victoire finale des
démocraties mais à une condition c'est
qu'elle le veuille YVES SAINT un jour
cette qui ça
libéral français libéral français
Raymond a vraiment très bien ça ne
pouvait être que de Raymond
[Musique]